good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast today's episode is
brought to you by betterhelp it doesn't
matter who you are or what you have life
can be pretty damn hard and without a
healthy mind it's even harder check out
online therapy with betterhelp.com toast
and be on your way to a little more ease
good morning everyone good morning
claudia good morning mr brew
good morning what to what do we owe the
pleasure of being graced by bruno's
presence wouldn't even get you know a
weak lead-up we got nothing well bruno's
mom has learned better than to promise
brew make promises she can't keep
because bruce schedule is so erratic so
unpredictable he is just so
out of control in terms of what he wants
to do he heard what you said about
talking [ __ ] about him and he just
[ __ ] bounces no he just needs a break
because he's preparing himself anyways
this morning i decided i want to win
brew it's a beautiful day and brew and i
were cooped up all weekend and
i am worried that he is agoraphobic so
he needs to get out of the house more
i'm going to try and bring him once a
week and i just felt like everybody
could benefit from the positive
influence of brew that is true but i did
also hear he had ulterior motives for
coming because you said that bruto has
an announcement to make he does have an
announcement that he wanted to make and
he's like mom you have this amazing
platform you have such an amazing
audience and of full of like
kind-hearted people and he said and i
want to let and he's shy so he won't say
it and i'm going to say for him he's
like i want to let everyone know because
i wanted to do a grand gesture for
knowles
and he said he wanted to come on the
show and let everyone know that he is in
love with magnolia okay i'm slightly
disappointed i thought you had something
actual to say like what would i have to
say i don't know like a pregnancy update
for us like i don't know i thought you
were gonna use this as an opportunity
still pregnant so pregnant still a boy
boy good good good yeah no but he is
just he's excited to be here you know
and i'm so excited to have him it's a
treat it's a treat for me hi my little
sweet brew and he is mommy's
best friend like and he's mommy's
protector and he does everything that he
can to make sure mom is happy and
comfortable happy and healthy and so
whatever brunch brew gets and he was
running towards the door this morning i
was like
i said
get over here you said to brew get in
loser we're going to the toast
um uh actually speaking of going to the
toast part of me was very hesitant to
show up here today
because if you know if let's say i died
over the weekend and my last episode on
earth was friday's episode like i would
be so at peace i don't even want to
record another episode because i don't
even want to like push friday's episode
like back into the archive like it is
the best episode of the toast ever i
watched it like four times that is so
funny i mean i think you would be
surprised if you watched more episodes
of the toast that they're all really
funny no i know
really funny i know when it's time to
re-watch the toast and i know when it's
not time i know when it's not time but i
do think like if you just went to a
random episode i think you would be like
really pleased with
what we do here i guess when i watch it
on the day of i'm very critical because
i'm like new information that's come out
about a story i think you could have
been more analytical but so maybe maybe
you're right when i'm too in it
sometimes i can't i can't say yeah it's
true
oh my god but no i feel you friday's
episode was hilarious i watched some of
it with brew and that also was like he
was like i want to be a part of this
like what you guys are creating it's
magic yeah and i want to put my stamp on
it too yeah i feel that 100 and he saw
do like looking so sexy and he was like
i can do that if you can do it while i
can um how was the rest of your weekend
what did you do my weekend was really
low-key i was mostly home chilling just
like watching stuff and reading stuff so
i i will share the current journey that
i'm on you know it's definitely not
pop culture related whatsoever um but
i've i've gotten a lot of positive
feedback from some of our listeners who
are interested in historical factoids so
i'll be sharing that as well
right now or
um no i'll wait till a little content
section okay how was your weekend it was
good it was actually valley balance like
friday night i spent in i read a book it
was delightful
and then saturday night you know raged
to the break of dawn 6am like spent the
whole day recovering yesterday now i'm
definitely feeling better
and i'm also feeling like
i'm gonna
turn a new leaf i think what will this
leaf entail i don't know i just think
like
i can't explain it like it's the time
between rosh hashanah and yom kippur
which is like an important time
and i think you're really supposed to
use it to reflect on where you're at in
your life
and bruno i'm trying to say something we
have a problem he sees my scrunchie and
he wants okay
i'm in the middle of a i can't take my
scrunchie out because my hair's not done
so i'm in the middle of the monologue
about self-worth maybe you should just
sit down and listen listen to your
auntie whatever i'm just feeling like
i'm going to use this time until
thursday i cannot believe yom kippur is
on thursday like
you can't even commiserate with me
that's like half the fun you know i'm
actually quite looking forward to you
poor because it's like i get all of the
the benefits of repenting for my sins
like turning off my phone
from work really being present in like
what i want out of this year and like
what i want to do differently
while also having a snack that's so nice
for you
um
i'm not really looking forward to it but
i am looking forward to this journey i
think i'm going to spend the next few
days really just
thinking about
you know who am i
that's a great question what am i doing
with my life you know
and that's what i'm going to be doing
for the next few days and it's going to
be a dark few days because you know
before the dawn
it's always darkest before the time so
you're turning over a new leaf for the
next few days
no no and then and then do you think
that'll inspire you to like plant a new
tree or you're gonna turn the leaf back
no i think that i'm gonna
turn the leaf in these next few days in
the sense of like really taking a look
inward okay and
depending on what i see
i will have to enact the change is
necessary but i'm not sure what i see
yet okay i think that that's exactly
what these days are meant for right
that's what i'm trying to do i mean if
it's not too personal i would love to
hear what you see i'll let you know i'm
i'm having a hard time
like looking at myself because you know
i think i'm so great and there's like
nothing wrong with me yeah but i do
think that there's some areas i could
grow in i feel like i've definitely
gotten better in the whole lush and
horror department which is like gossip
and speaking ill of people i mean
technically it's what i do for a living
so it's hard not to but i just mean like
my personal life i'm really not like a
[ __ ] talker okay
so that's one thing
i think another thing i think
i think i'm a great friend
and sister
but i do think you know i'm
somewhat
self-involved just a little
like when people talk to me not you
obviously cuz like obsessed but when
like other people like talk to me about
like what's going on in their lives like
i really don't care yeah and i feel like
that's super rude but i think that's on
them for being boring
thank you 100
100
but like no that's like not what being a
good friend is like i'm always just like
steamrolling over people just so i can
like say like for me a conversation is
like waiting for you to be done so like
i could share my interesting life you
know like i went to paris hilton's
engagement party on saturday like why am
i listening to you you know
but that's not fair and that's not what
friendship is so i'm just really gonna
work unless you were friends with only
people who went to paris hilton's
engagement party but like that's not the
life i want you know okay good to know
so i don't know i'm just gonna work on
being a good friend and a good sister
and a good person you know like yeah you
know i should volunteer more you know
you know so much going on and kobed like
i know it's hard but um so this is just
a few things i'm thinking about i've
really only started this self journey
discovery like yesterday i need some
time yeah and when you said like you
don't really know like where to start on
looking inward i feel like there might
be some
pamphlets or like questionnaires online
that would help you that are like trying
to help you
self-think do you know what i mean yeah
i also look for some resources i think a
good resource is like just going up to
the important people in my life and like
asking what's annoying about me
i mean that's also a hurtful way of
going about it but i do think like
probably effective yeah you could do it
i don't think it will end well for you
do you have something you want to say
well if you really like if you wanted to
know like like
everything that there is to know but you
don't i don't want to know everything do
you know something no no is everyone
talking about me behind my back no no
but like you know everybody has their
thing about them yeah it's fine
we could talk about it later
oh my god i have a pen no you're fine
yeah whatever like i was just really and
i think you know you don't have to be
jewish to use this time
it's a special time it really is look
inward
think
observe reflect repent
heal
um but before i heal like can i just
gossip about what i did this weekend
yeah of course so on saturday by the way
why can't a good person like talk about
their weekend i know it's not really
gossip it's just like an exchanging of
information especially if it's about
yourself what you did and honestly i
just want to say like i don't really
subscribe to the notion that
you gossiping makes you a bad person
because no it depends because you told
me about a gossip this weekend i just
sounded like a bad person it was okay
there's a difference between an exchange
of information and like
what the thing i told you and it's all
about the intent nefarious intentions
yes that's it if you're like mindlessly
gossiping just like about mindlessness i
heard this part like just sharing you
know update like i heard they're
separated like they are separated so i'm
not making [ __ ] up updates updates
and what is your reason for letting the
person know that they're separated is it
nefarious that's a good it usually is
i don't know
seems harmless
okay um no i just had a great time i
went to paris engagement party on
saturday and i really like got to know
the couple you know
and it totally
didn't phase me up until that moment
was paris
found a businessman beau
he's actually the definition of a
businessman beau
um
and i just think that like this is otp
for paris like it's over like it's over
it usually is when you found a
businessman though and it just it didn't
even occur to me like why i thought they
were so cute until like you know he his
um
like best friend spoke and they worked
together at golem and i'm like oh he was
talking coleman and i'm like this is
smelling like a businessman beau
situation and that's exactly what it was
and it was so fun and kathy was there
and most importantly
i don't even know if i told you this but
kris jenner and corey gamble were there
you told me that
and
you would think i would be like
flustered and forklamped in the pres
presence of kris jenner like not at all
he felt at ease my knees went weak at
the sign of corey gamble
and he hugged the person next to me and
like we brushed shoulders and i swear to
god like i almost fainted like i'm i'm
really not the kind to get star struck
but cory gamble like has has your heart
has my heart and just seeing this power
couple and like being in the presence of
them
it was everything of the story chris is
so [ __ ] cool and stunning and
gorgeous amy schumer was there too which
i thought was so random
and it was just so lovely to celebrate
love and
celebrities hmm my two favorite things
your two favorite things speaking of two
things do you know that your earrings
are different you're lying
or maybe they're the master the ombre
ones oh there but then the other one
starts with pink and ends with blue
let me see so i think they go together
but it looks like two okay gas slider my
earrings are exactly the same stuff
that's not gaslighting yes like being
confused and asking a question no you're
like you're going to literally tell me
that my i think you're fighting my
earrings are different until i believe
it oh please gaslighting is one of the
most overused words but it's also such
an effective word
when true
so please don't abuse the term no ben
software literally figured out what
gaslighting is like two months ago and
now like if i make a joke i'm
gaslighting him like he's so annoying no
but also yeah and then he realized like
his life is being lit with gas literally
no like whoever told ben about
gaslighting like is so annoying and is
my enemy
no there's this phrase on tick tock
gaslight
gatekeep girl boss so that's really like
about mlm
um culture okay and people oh by the way
have you heard about this lularoe okay
so i saw someone posted about it and
like that there's an amazon show about
lularoe and i was like i have no idea
who that is i have to watch it and then
i saw it on my tv so i just clicked it
just to see what it was and apparently
lularoo is not a person but a mlm it's
an mlm started by this like turnt couple
who like brainwashed women into like
selling their own breast milk to afford
their ugly printed leggings like
and this the the whole it's such a crazy
story but like made crazy by the fact
like you see these clothes like you will
die like they're so [ __ ] heinous and
ugly and atrocious and like the fact
that like this billion dollar company
and this huge like global scam was
started off some of the ugliest clothes
you've ever seen in your life maybe i
will watch it because i really don't i
can't wrap my head around mlms and i
don't really have a strong opinion yeah
about them because i just don't
understand it fully right because i
think like when you first like take a
look at a situation about an mlm well
it's like well if you don't like the
company don't work for it right like no
one i'm not selling murder in fields
right right but i think there is like an
emotional element to mlms and like
pyramid scheme companies that literally
prey on like the vulnerable in a
cult-like way
so it's like super unethical which is
why like at face value it's like okay
it's like a weird thing but like so you
don't like it don't sell eyelash serum
like it's like yeah but these companies
are built to like
keep
vulnerable people working for them and
like you have to recruit more girls like
it's [ __ ] crazy like so i don't know
because i'm not really like into mlm
culture but that's why it's like so
toxic and unethical and i do want to
watch the lularoe but
if you do join like is it just the like
toxicity
that's bad about it or is it also like a
ponzi scheme it's like a schemey vibes
okay so like or if you do like sometimes
with those mlms like there are the women
who like got a car yeah yeah okay but so
the thing is like with the car the car
is like a perfect example and so i've
like fallen on mlm side of tick tock
okay so the car is like actually like
[ __ ] you over because like you get it
for free but like you have to maintain
all the payments and like the insurance
for a car that you really can't afford
that's why someone gave it to you for
free yeah and the car can like literally
put people in debt okay yeah okay but
like i once watched an episode of
american green about a an mlm
company and not only were they like just
preying on vulnerable people but there
was no
there was nothing okay so that's a
scheme but like multi-level marketing
companies are
like [ __ ] up fundamentally because you
are required like you are an employee of
a company and you are required to spend
like ten thousand dollars to buy the
product that you then sell to other
people and try and like recruit your
friends too yeah so like why do i need
to
spend ten thousand dollars to get a job
yeah but i mean it just mary kay
cosmetics is an mlm yes but i think it's
like one of the most like dignified i
mean it's very like respected and it's a
company i think yeah so
no you're what are they doing that the
others aren't what makes i bet that's a
good question this is why i need to
watch documentary that's a good question
i have no [ __ ] idea yeah okay cool
cool i'm so not down the mlm rabbit hole
and i worry if i take it it's a it's a
major responsibility to take off i'm
worried if i take a step in and then i'm
into like mlm then you know just
there's so much content there so much
you know and it's just that's a lot no
but this like this documentary is making
a lot of waves so i don't think i it's a
tv show or documentary documentary i'm
gonna watch it okay cool and like
lularoe you know i just can't stop
saying it i didn't know what it was
maybe the show was called rich
it's a good name yeah um so yeah that's
what i did this weekend think about mlms
and yeah
very fun well
this weekend was
this weekend and then last night
literally was spent watching like four
hours of television wheelhouse was of
potomac of course but then we also like
it really crept up on me this season
premiere of real housewives
honestly i was like ugh another thing on
my plate for tonight i just wanted to go
back to watching my rick burns
documentary
but then it started and i was enchanted
the real house of salt lake city editing
is so unique and different than any
other housewives franchise like the
music the scenery the latter day saints
like it's really gorgeous like i it
usually takes a few episodes to get into
a show
i mean the way that they started last
night's episode chilling hooked me in
because you know what it really is so
crazy and sad but like i really do get
fatigued by these national news stories
that like play out for so long before we
even get to the footage
and so i was like i was already over the
season before it started yeah they
railed me back in like
a hundred percent of them and even
beyond the gen shaw stuff there's other
things going on in the show
there's other things going on in the
show that i
like care about just as much you know
like yeah it's so good we'll get into
the recap that salt lake city um we're
gonna break down the vmas today's the
first monday in may you know what
i don't feel like i've ever seen
it's the second monday in september
wait
what yeah the met gala is always the
first monday in may you're right yeah
but then we missed a year and a half
worth of met gala and then they moved it
to september i guess to coincide with
fashion week and now it's just on a
random monday in september oh yeah it's
certainly not the first monday and may
thank you so much for bringing that up i
really appreciate it i think a lot of
people will be confused tonight when
they see them back out and be like is it
may it's unseasonably chilly for may
okay so it's
the faux
monday in may yeah but i don't feel like
i've ever remember having this much
anticipation for like who's going like i
just like i usually like don't even care
but i'm just
i guess it's because so many celebrities
are in town for fashion week and for the
vmas so now it's like who's going to
stay overnight one more night yeah well
not because like they're gonna wait but
like because they weren't invited like
everyone right now looks like every
celebrity who's in new york is going to
the mecca log that's and we're about to
separate the boys from the men the wheat
from the chief dumois posted last night
that both justin bieber and kylie jenner
fled town and
like dropped out of the met gala which
is so crazy because honestly like if
kylie's not there like i literally
couldn't care less the ball just went
down from like
i would say even this year it's at a
seven because apparently it's like super
illusory like there's a lot of like
losery things happening so i would say
was this seven and now kylie's not there
it's a five
well here's the thing if addison ray
goes
it goes back up to a seven like i
addison right is going for sure well so
well she said she said i'll watch what
happens i don't know what i know i watch
oh my god star you guys star alert it
was crazy she was just the cutest thing
um except like andy would only ask her
questions about kourtney kardashian it
was like this girl is so much so much
more than that they had a whole segment
about like
what does courtney do like that's so
like different titles same concept i
have to say like edison ray's so
interesting and like her being friends
with courtney is like the least
interesting thing about her there's so
much more to know and like towards the
end of the question she was like these
aren't my questions to answer it was
they asked her like what does she think
about scott's message to eunice
and she was like that's hella
inappropriate so inappropriate okay
anyways but she just like radiated off
the screen like it was as she should he
asked if she was going to gala and she
said that she could not say
and then they were like why and she's
like i'm just following everyone else's
lead everyone else who's going to the
mecca oh she's for sure okay that's
amazing i've heard that emma chamberlain
is going to which is not really
surprising because she's like the face
of louis vuitton digital yeah and did
she not go in the past like that i
believe she went once that year that
james charles went that's weird and we
probably went yep
honestly no
okay but like let me think hold on let
me just google a picture i don't think
she's ever been
okay but she should be there that's not
like yeah no that like when i saw like
jimoh posted that she might be going oh
yeah she's been once no
no she has an itunes yeah no she's such
a fashion girly and like i'm sure she'll
be at the youtube table
well it's not tables by
job it's tables by designer it's tables
by brands designer yeah
youtube is a brand oh you think
youtube's no she's gonna be at the louis
vuitton table uh you think yeah 100 like
her and sophie turner oh my god and
someone else was just in a louis vuitton
ad
i swear it was charlie tomelio
no yeah
you're live like i'm pretty sure hold on
let me just look it up i saw so anya
taylor joy is definitely going of course
she is fashion she is elegance she is
the moment
do you think me and kelly are going yes
and i actually think for the first time
courtney kardashian is going to be
invited to the met gala she's in town i
don't think she would have just come to
town for the vmas and like she has had a
year like i'm sorry like she is the most
interesting to look at currently so i
actually think she might get invited
unfortunately chloe it's still gonna be
a no from anna wintour um and i don't
think chloe like will
ever get invited to the met gala if she
keeps doing you know sponsored posts for
sheehan but
louis vuitton emma and charlie together
oh my gosh it's like whole campaign is
there an age limit i mean age minimum
no at the met gala like you have to be
21 to attend no
okay because like charlie's in town the
demilious went to the vms last night
dixie and charlie looked so [ __ ] cute
they did we're gonna talk about the
amazing style i mean i didn't watch the
show so i'm just we're gonna talk about
the things that you saw on the internet
not from watching the chat so oh my god
charlie definitely is coming and
honestly like dixie could go too yeah
she could i mean i actually don't think
courtney and travis will be there i kind
of do
do you think me gun is going to be there
it's either all or nothing because
they're really the same you know they
also went like to dinner the four of
them after the vmas last night did you
know they're happy to see what
restaurant it was i couldn't figure it
out no but you want me to find out
dumont definitely has it
yeah we could do it later um
why'd the food look good no i just like
i like to know where you know where the
peeps are going yeah exactly
but
do i think the four
the core four will be there this is the
thing like do you do they want it to be
like an event full of relevant people
then they should be invited but like
they're very invitations like went out a
while ago
but maybe she keeps adding people but
you definitely shouldn't give your
dresses like so far but no but if if
invitations went out like for the
original mac out like a year and a half
ago like addison would have never been
on the list so like things can change um
i think that she would have but
courtney wouldn't have no but like
things
does travis has travis ever been like
wow like so separately they're not good
enough but together they might be they
might
does it work like that for anna i don't
know what designers are they friendly
with that's
that's a good call that's the thing it's
not even about like how famous you are
it's like relationships with designers
but to me like one of my the most
interesting you know
dynamics in all of pop culture
is the fact that like there is this
family of like seven famous women and
two of them have never been
kylie and kendall go chris goes kim goes
courtneying and
chloe never get invited and they never
talk about it like i would just love to
know does it bother chloe does she want
to go like i want to know i think that
if courtney goes it will bother chloe of
course just to be the only one and also
like when you think about the success of
the show and the girls like it's so much
of it has to do with chloe like she put
that show on her back for years like in
the beginning she was everyone's
favorite like and just for them to be at
this level now and like she's just
getting left behind like i think about
it all the time i just feel like so the
way that it goes is like brands buy
tables they invite celebrities that they
want to dress or sit with and then anna
has to approve the celebrities that they
invited yes i think the kardashians
should buy a table
right like skims
or like even if hulu bought a table for
them but i think i don't know that
brands other than fashion designers can
buy tables
i'm pretty sure like youtube buys a
table that's why james charles was there
no james charles was with alexander wang
huh
i'm pretty sure it's like only designers
like to keep intact the integrity of so
it doesn't become this like commercial
event where like people are like putting
up billboards like okay so games should
buy a table right good american could i
i'm sure you have to get approved to buy
a table and like adam would never
approve good america but at a certain
point like it's about it's a fundraiser
and so if you want to outbid a table
like
are you trying to raise money or are you
not do you think taylor's going she's
like always you know on like she's a
committee her harry styles and rihanna
like
run the met gala like with anna i don't
know what she's up to so you would know
better than me oh and honestly i don't
feel like she will ever go to an event
that kim kardashian's at now that i
think about it yeah and you think
kanye's going oh i don't know
that's a good question he's probably not
but now that i think about it like
taylor's definitely not going
that's so crazy i know um
like well honestly like when will
when will taylor ever go to the met gala
again because kim is always going to be
there and now it's like overrun with
kardashians like they take over that's
what all the like insider articles say
after that it's just like a kardashian
affair honestly they should put like a
kardashian on the
gala committee because that chloe can
come no not not only that because like
they really are the epicenter of pop
culture like they're friends with
everyone they bring everyone together
they make the most iconic moments on
social media i was actually just
thinking that because i was looking at
who's the one for this year and i was
like
it should be a kardashian soon it really
should be him
and it could be clo it could be kylie it
could be chloe
yeah you could accept that like kim is
so oh kendall yeah yeah kim is so
involved she's so fashiony like yeah she
so is kendall
yeah but kendall is like
as work not as pleasure if that makes
sense i i understand what you're saying
whatever oh all to say bringing me back
to my original thought is i'm so excited
to see who shows up like really truly i
am too i forget what the theme is um
it's american
it's just american it's like america
colon you know
something so like if somebody starts
showing up in like stars in
[ __ ] stripes you know meskina
will do that yeah like something really
tacky like that's what i want
casey musgraves is definitely going she
was in town for the vmas and she looked
i'm sorry atrocious last night so
hopefully and i was wondering who she
was wearing but i couldn't find it
because i feel like whoever she was
wearing is like who she's here with you
know maybe mosquito was last year i feel
like it would probably be the same and
that outfit was like kind of mosquito i
feel like she i feel like i saw the
designer that she was wearing and it
wasn't moschino oh but i forget um
i feel like she'll go with messino again
me too she looked amazing last year as
barbie yeah like three years ago but
yeah oh my god yeah yeah no it's
actually it's exciting to like have
something to look forward to and i
really am excited to see the fashions
because we haven't seen like fashion
inspo in years i know and the mecca is
so weird because it's like such a
talked about event but it's not
televised so like
there's an e red there's an e red carpet
but there's no like event i mean i'm
good with just pictures honestly me too
like 100 i get to like sit in my bed
watch something else and just scroll
yeah sounds good to me i don't have to
watch like them try and make
conversation on the red carpet no ease
pre-show to the pre-show before the show
predicting what stars will wear yeah
it's so dumb yeah um so i just can't
[ __ ] wait so
same yeah that will be exciting to to
discuss and yes this weekend definitely
felt like a lead up too so we'll see
what happens here um but i'm ready to
dive in if you are i feel like we've i'm
ready to dive in as well because our
first story is just a continuation of
what we've been speaking about so
without further ado
here are the past five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
curology curology customizes a
prescription formula with three active
ingredients picked for you to help
tackle your skincare needs whether that
may be maybe trying to take control of
acne or if acne is no longer your top
skin concern fine lines dark spots
occasional breakouts or clogged pores
you start by answering questions online
about your skin and if it's a good fit
then curology will match you with a
licensed dermatology provider who will
get to know your skin and subject to
consultation you'll get a customized
prescription cream to be shipped
straight to your door to address your
acne fine lines dark spots and more
honestly the concept of curology is so
smart it's like we all have different
skin like why are we using the same
products their quiz is like super in
depth you actually take pictures of your
face like the middle the right side the
left side and you ask and they ask a ton
of questions you answer a ton of stuff
about your skin and it really feels like
what you get in the mail is tailor made
for you because it is and i just love
the idea that like
no one has the same one as me because
like no one has my skin
um you can start your curology journey
just like we did with the free 30-day
trial at curology.com toast if
prescribed just pay five dollars for
shipping and handling that's
c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y dot com toast to unlock
your free 30-day trial cancel anytime go
get that glow
thank you claudia it's a pleasure
our first story is a bit of vmas red
carpet news recap travis and courtney
megan and mgk and more celebrity couples
hit the red carpet and we'll also talk
about some of our favorite looks i mean
by far my best dress was camila cabello
and i don't know if that's because she's
always flopping on the red carpet that
like my shock
is in overdrive but she just looked
glorious finally like she's literally
one of the prettiest girls ever and
she's just like always not doing it like
at all yeah i feel you yeah i'll go to
the mac ella her and sean yes yes me too
yes for sure and he is probably one of
my worst dressed me too oh my god like
the pants that were not hemmed
the like saggy i don't know it's just
it's giving very much like divorcee on
her porch in nantucket like yeah you
know on a chilly night yeah i agree um i
looked at a lot of the pictures like
nothing really stands out to me i
thought charlie and dixie looked really
cute and i thought they looked cute
together together because and also it
just like harks back to the show where
it's like charlie's pink and dixie's
like
and i think it was like very unbrand for
them i completely agree i thought they
looked amazing nobody like stood out
completely as like drop dead or terrible
um except honestly like on one of my
worst dress is casey musgraves which is
so upsetting and by the way she was
wearing valentino
it's it's not gonna work for me okay um
the headpiece was really just like too
campy to the point where it's just plain
ugly like the dress was cute the gloves
were cute but like all together it
wasn't a look i actually love the dress
on its own that's like a dress that i
would wear yeah like no gloves no hat
just like i love the cut of it no and
even with the gloves it was cute and
like different but the hat just was like
it's just
yeah but you know what like at least
she's gonna flop let it be last night no
of course like but she's really like
constantly slaying her looks like it was
just so unlike her to i almost didn't
recognize her because i'm like this is
an ugly outfit why don't i recognize the
person wearing it because the person
wearing it always looks like a 10 out of
10. yeah i i agree with that but overall
like it wasn't like a show-stopping red
carpet by any only person people who
stopped the show were like megan kelly
because her look was so
sickening i mean but also people were
freaking out because it looked so
similar to kim's most recent macale look
where her hair was wet and she wore like
that really tight terry mugler everyone
was like that's what everyone i was
saying on social media that like she
looked so much like her one i didn't
really think it like at first i couldn't
reference that moment at all but then
everyone was saying it so i was like i
guess like technically yeah i didn't
reference that moment at all but like
okay so who cares it was she was
inspired no kim's a fashion icon like we
should all be following in her footsteps
yeah that's fine by me and by the way
so she followed a kim kardashian makeup
tutorial and this is how it turned out
like we should all be thanking kim like
literally megan looks unbelievably
gorgeous and stunning right and we got a
sweet moment also another viral moment
was just like mgk getting into a fight
with conor mcgregor yeah that was very
bizarre conor mcgregor somebody got it
on camera like basically they just like
started he just started throwing hands
like threw a drink and megan was caught
in the middle like what the [ __ ] is
going on it was so bizarre i don't know
what their beef is but like you know
when i heard that these two people were
beefing like i wasn't really surprised
yeah that was just random very random
and
like who cares yeah so i didn't see any
of the performances neither did you i
saw olivia rodriguez like she was
actually what is she saying
[Music]
good for you
yeah all of her songs sound the same and
kim petra sing a song that i didn't know
but like we stan kim petrus and kim
petrus is definitely going to the mac
gala okay i mean that's what
that's
tomasso
you can't tell me like just tell me when
it's your prediction versus oh no okay
so um kim petrus addison ray emma
chamberlain we're all from
chiang mai like i can't but i just was
thinking camilla and john like they go
separately so they would go together
sean went
no they're going to be like sickening
together yeah no it's going to be great
i'm going to see i'm excited for like
the fashion and you know what vma
fashion like i do feel like everyone's
trying to like
have to do like and just like it's
definitely you don't wear you know your
little lbd your sunday best so it's
outrageous yeah that's what we got
that's true it's like very
like costumey almost everyone shows up
in a costume yeah but then you also look
back on the pictures like from 10 years
ago and it's like those are such vma
moments like the rose mcgowan moment
where she's like naked under that like
chain mail dress yeah or just like
britney and justin like wearing all
these yeah i'm like so the vma fashion
is meant to be a little silly
crazy yeah it's true yeah
next up some happy couple news britney
spears and sam ashkari are engaged oh my
god yes she says i can't believe it the
couple announced their engagement on
sunday they first met in 2016.
this is amazing news because remember
when
she gave her speech at her
conservatorship hearing and she was
literally like i want to drive in the
car with my boyfriend like i want to get
married and have kids and like those
were things that seemed to her like not
in the realm of possibility and now here
she is like engaged and she's being like
so chuggy about it i love it like
honestly like with the inspirational
quotes and like this picture yeah
she's with like her middle finger she's
so chewy it's like so cute how like
excited she is no i agree and i said
last week that i was gonna be suspicious
about like jamie stepping down from the
conservatorship until we saw like
brittany doing the things that he said
that she couldn't do and that she wanted
to do and like this is one of those
things and so now i'm like
you guys it's all happening no this is
an amazing sign for what's to come like
i don't want to get too excited but like
this is huge yeah it's just this looks
like freedom it smells like freedom and
it tastes like freedom i think it's
freedom
no it's amazing so happy for britney
ashgari like how cute and literally just
like
i came to the realization that britney
was chuggy like two days ago and it's
like the funniest thing ever because she
really is like her quotes her dance
saying like chew galicious oh beyond
beyond like yeah honestly they should
link her instagram to the urban
dictionary like definition of chugi yeah
but then it's like she's so chewy it's
like chewier than the tubes no honestly
she's so chewy that it's now borderline
ironic you know it's like not even chewy
how chewy she i agree
because chewiness is like a subtle nod
it's also like a state of mind totally
just like bruce do you think bruno is
chewy no because his mom is just not no
his mom is so original and like
nerve talent
yes that's what he says about mom yeah
are you ready for our next story it's a
little more happy couple news and i mean
it's not really news other than just
like
ben and jen have made their romance
official red carpet official in venice
okay dennis i saw your story it's a
venice film festival oh i just like
forget that there are other film
festivals outside of canada because like
irrelevant a great toronto film festival
like no agreed um okay
gorgeous like first of all he like looks
so messy sometimes but like he got a
haircut he shaved his face like he
looked amazing she looked
heavenly oh wait so if they're in venice
they have to be going to the met gala
now
i don't know why i feel like they're not
i know because they're so busy they're
in another country but like jlo is the
moment like no she was at the vms last
night oh she was yeah but ben wasn't
there okay because like honestly
he's too good for the viewers i'm sorry
he's too old
totally maybe he's definitely going for
tomorrow oh my god she's here okay by
the way that will be like a huge thing
honestly they should have like waited to
make their debut because like okay i
know it's probably a big deal but like
venice film festival is like so mad no
but you know what i think that actually
this is more iconic because like the
looks here like he's wearing just like a
bow tie in a suit and she's wearing a
stunning white dress the metallic you're
like in a costume yeah i think they have
to wear face masks throughout too so
like i don't want to i don't want that
to be on the carpet though they have to
wear that's i read up in page six like
all of the things that are happening for
this year's mac gala and masks that
match the outfits are one of those but
definitely not for the red carpet
there's no one around you when you're on
the red carpet oh my god that would suck
right okay so you're right i'm glad we
got our moment with ben and she got to
like wear just like the most beautiful
dress oh my god she doesn't have to be
like fashion high-end like her body
looking so
gorgeous and like curvy and like she
just is
the moment like i keep saying that but
she is
and i thought those pictures and videos
of them from the red carpet were
adorable except so i read this book you
know i told you fix her up yes i watched
your story but so share your theory with
the class okay so in this book like
georgie these two characters like you
know enter into a fake relationship like
they both have their own reasons like he
wants to clear up his reputation she
wants people to take her more seriously
like it's moronic and of course they
fall in love in the end
um
but then like i was watching these
videos from ben and jen i'm like this is
like too
perfect it's almost like rehearsed how
stunning these photos are the kissing of
the head like it's it's gorgeous but
it's too much then i'm like maybe ben
and jen entered into a agreement a la
travis and georgie from the book
and they're both looking to get things
out of their
arrangement like of course what does jlo
get out of this like no one's talking
about a-rod anymore a-rod's the biggest
loser of all time she won in every
possible way like people are obsessed
like the memorabilia of it all the the
like flashbacks to the 90s like
nostalgia you mean thank you that's the
word i was looking for
you're welcome keep going keep going
like jayla's just getting jayla's just
getting like every possible thing out of
his channel's on top of the world i
think jayla was a bigger star now than
she's ever been like literally because
she smashed a rod into the ground and
now
ben like what does he get like
he literally went through like the
roughest couple years like with the
whole you know divorce thing and then
the nanny and the snl writer like he
just had the worst reputation
the tattoo all we saw like were like bad
pictures of him like picking up dunkin
donuts coffee like he was just like a
mess and so now he's dating literally
the most beautiful woman in the world
he's back on top like he's back at
venice film festival like when was the
last time ben affleck got out of bed
before jayla like i'm telling you never
not that i'm anyone to judge but like
you know what i mean so i just think
that like we are now in a place where
the two
a-listers who've like you know ebbed and
flowed in their fame are like at the
actual height of of their famousness
like i don't think jlo's ever been more
popular and i don't think ben affleck
actually maybe like the goodwill hunting
days but you know what i mean i don't
think he's ever been more cemented into
hollywood a-list royalty than he is
right now like him and j-lo got it so
perhaps i'm gonna say
it's a possibility but i want to believe
don't you think like the book i'm sure
ended up that you know you just like
every great hallmark movie no by the way
you've got to get together for the
holidays because so your parents don't
ask for holidays yeah and then you fall
in love no this ruse will ultimately end
up in the greatest love story of our
time and i think they're already in the
love phase i think so this is how i
think it's playing out in the book
version ben is falling hard
because like how can you not fall for
j.lo and jayla's like really just trying
to not give into her feelings like she
is focused on the plan like there's so
many benefits like this will not work
out if they start to follow benefits
this will not work out if they start to
fall for each other like she's the one
not really like giving in but then like
he'll make an emotional like monologue
about how like they're meant to be and
how like they were meant to be in this
fake relationship and like after all
this time has passed like it's like no
time has passed at all and then jayla
will give in and they'll live happily
ever after okay so you don't think she's
they've
fallen into each other yet that they've
no i think ben that they've let all
their walls down no ben has head over
heels and like jayla's trying hard not
to
give she's been burned she's been burned
and she's seen the success of the
arrangement like right if it gets
complicated with feelings and sex like
it won't work right but the heart wants
what it wants and the heart wants ben
from jen for sure
and then they live happily ever after
okay
i will neither like i i think anything's
possible you know i first thought these
two were entering into business together
so what do i know for a competitive male
skin care line
called
him
himself
are you ready for our next story it's a
little more fashion news this is such a
fashiony episode for us i mean we're so
fashion well i guess because it's
fashion week yeah i know whenever i call
about fashion week the bar has never
been lower for people to invite
well that's actually probably in tandem
with my call which is that
this week of fashion week felt like a
week-long fashions night out
oh my god fashion's night out i totally
like where all these brands are inviting
like influencers to like come and then
like the people come to to like shop
because everything's like shoppable and
like ready to wear well that's like
revolve
revolves influence yes no but that's
what it feels like it just feels like
one long fashion tonight out where it's
not like about high fashion it's just
about like consumer
consuming well honestly i really felt
like i was watching two fashion weeks
happen like following people like derek
last week like seeing like the actual
high fashion like tom ford
um
dior like all these like you know
elegance showed in new york yeah okay i
didn't even see that and then there was
like the revolve influence or the tick
tockers like going to like
you know like
other brands like not like super super
high fashion but like you know more
accessible brands contemporary yes thank
you so much um
so i really felt like there were two
fashion weeks coming on like which was
like kind of cool because like the
revolve one with all the tick talkers
like was super accessible like i think
that it was
like i think they're selling clothes
this week you know right and then i'm
sure the other ones that are like more
high fashion like i don't i didn't even
see it but
it's like
who's buying i don't know
yeah
yeah no i i like the carolina herrera
like there you either went to carolina
herrera or you went to
try to think of like like the like
dundas sure or like wherever the revolve
one was you know like but revolve owns
like all those brands they're all like
collabs it's literally so smart yeah
yeah yeah and like you look at like the
people who went to the revolve events
and it was like a such a diverse group
of people body like everything and like
it was the same four people at all like
the fancy shows but there were two
fashion weeks going on in my opinion
yeah and
just the
more attainable one the revolve vibe one
just was giving me like fashion's night
out by where it's just like about
celebrating like closing buying [ __ ]
yeah it was um that's a great call
actually fascinating night out for those
who don't know what fashion's night out
was like when we were in high school it
was okay so one night a year it was one
night a year but it only lasted like
three or four years it was a new idea
and then it ended abruptly and it was
just this idea i guess it was not a
success every store like and it was
started
was it i'm pretty sure okay so like
every major store in the city would stay
open
at night even though they usually close
at like seven it was like during fashion
week so it was one night during fashion
week that was meant to be forever for
everyone so like every store would stay
open and like have events activations
like come get your makeup done
like celebrities who they like hire to
be they're just like influencers this
was before influencers yeah so like they
would have a celebrity to be there and
then like oh i want to go see so and so
let's go here and every anyone could go
like you didn't need to be invited like
you would walk into bendel's and like
walk around you could she would shop and
it was really like a fun thing we went
when we were in high school it was meant
to like boost
commerce yeah i think it did enough for
ben dell's but um but
i don't think it was a success at all
because it literally lasted four years
it was fun though yeah but i do think
this fashion week to me like just feels
like a long fashions night out that's a
really good question it's just like for
everyone it's more accessible yeah we
all love fashion we oh yeah
okay are you ready for our next fashion
story only if it's a story that's
brought to you by manscaped because
autumn is in the air the pumpkins are in
the patch and our friends at manscaped
are here to make sure your man doesn't
carve his pants pumpkins when he's
grooming if you know what i'm saying
make sure he's keeping things fresh this
fall with the leaders in male grooming
in their brand new 4th generation
performance package ladies do we really
want to cuddle up to a dude who isn't
trimmed get him to take the leap into
fall with manscaped help him join over 2
million men worldwide using manscaped by
going to manscape.com for 20 off and
free shipping with the code toast so
they have a great bundle going on right
now they're performance package 4.0
where you can find the lawnmower 4.0
trimmer the weed whacker ear and nose
hair trimmer and the crop preserver ball
deodorant and toner plus two free gifts
so honestly like if your man's is not um
trimming his nose hair and his ear's
hair like grow up it's time this is a
great gift for someone like first of all
i got ben the performance package and
literally it comes with absolutely
everything and when he travels he just
throws it all they also come with great
um like cool travel cases
it comes with everything because like
boys don't know how to like shop for
themselves so if you just get like one
bundle and it's all they need for like
the rest of their lives right that's
really the best way to do it um you
could seal the deal with their manscaped
liquid formulations the crop preserver
ball deodorant everyone knows pumpkin
spice lattes and ball deodorant go hand
in hand and it's fall so like get your
man some ball deodorant get 20 off and
free shipping with the code toast at
manscape.com that's 20 off and free
shipping with the code toast at
manscape.com make sure his balls are
fresh this fall with manscaped so if you
want to show your man that you love him
take care of his balls yes thank you
claudia
it's a pleasure
next up kim kardashian west is making
another bold statement with her style
the keeping up with the kardashians alum
turned heads on saturday by racking a
head-to-toe leather ensemble by
balenciaga as she arrived in new york
city ahead of the met gallup i'm sure
you've all seen this look we must
discuss
because honestly like
remembering kim was in rome
yeah
and her and kanye were not together yep
and it was the hats and she was wearing
like slip dresses and hats which is just
like cute but like so basic like la
influencer like kim could never yeah
that's how we knew
things were on the rocks with kanye
now in this very weird
fashion art moment that i personally
don't understand i've never been more
sure that her and kanye aaron are on
amazing terms okay but plot twist as of
this morning he unfollowed her on
instagram she was the only person he was
following oh my god wait you're lying
because i thought it was sweet that like
even though they were getting divorced
like he still only followed like the
mother of his children like they don't
have to be together for him to like have
respect for her you know i saw i'm just
going to double check for myself even
though it was a headline like it's not
just you know screenshots
but let's just go that's does he follow
anyone now like what if he followed
irene and shane like i would be so
devastated okay we
he follows 12 people now oh and none of
them are
who does he follow him like the gap
fashion nova
really yes jules
wait
him following fashion nova is actually
like so bizarre yeah maybe they're doing
a collab
no because like because there was all
that drama they steal everyone's designs
like yeah okay who else um just but i
don't follow any one who he follows like
zero one eight
super danny
fonz bentley
i mean just not kim not kim yeah not all
people who are not kim not chloe not
kylie not kendall but he never followed
them
right and he low-key doesn't [ __ ] with
that [ __ ] stormy so
it's understandable that he wouldn't
follow kanye so yes i saw this and i'm
like kanye's back
the you know the family's back together
but now i don't know but also he could
be following people just like as you
know a marketing thing for those could
be his new partners of something also
like instagram's like not an actual
depiction of what's going on in the
world right and i'm glad that he it's
not like he just went from following him
to following zero like
the one he's pivoting it's like you know
when taylor unfollowed everyone right it
you know the and i don't think kanye
spends this much time oh kim hurt me i'm
unfollowing her yeah no that's not what
grown people think about also people are
really perplexed by the fact that like
travis got one of vma last night and he
thanked stormy but he didn't thank kylie
do you think that's like kylie's heading
back to l.a
because she's hurt she was supposed to
go with travis i'm ready dang no no that
i mean
she wouldn't cancel on the mac ella for
that but like i do think it was weird
she's literally pregnant like i know i
wonder oh my god i totally forgot
kylie's pregnant like if she did go to
the mac ella which i'm hearing that
she's not from tomorrow we would have
gotten literally the most
sickening like pregnancy met gala look
but at least we got some looks this week
yeah she
great she didn't get the vmas or
anything no but like she gave us some
good fashion looks yeah the moms to be
like we know to where to take our
marching orders like we're wearing lace
from top to bottom totally um and a big
coat she's about the big coat mm-hmm
now i'm even more sad that we're missing
like a kylie moment if we are i believe
like i just believe that i believe it
too um
yeah so travis didn't think kylie but
that's like not that surprising they're
just like not annoying like that and
they're not like pda at all and i don't
think that like his vma speech means
much to her do you know what i mean like
i don't know i feel like she was
watching i think she put up like an
instagram story that she was was she
yeah
i don't know i don't know kim put one up
because she was watching courtney and me
cute
yeah it was cute i don't think it
matters to her what he says at the
vietnamese yeah me neither but they're
just like not like a
i feel like they've walked one red
carpet together and it was the one
for his netflix documentary yeah with
the white dress yeah but then i think
they did one recently also i don't know
like
i would have just really liked just
having a family moment between like all
three of them they're having a family
moment they're having a baby you know i
know like on the red carpet i mean like
the three of them like the unborn fetus
travis and kylie and stormy the four of
them oh my god storm we should go yeah
honestly like it won't be long before
northwest is going to the met gala i
seriously can't wait i wonder if
whatever the age limit is like the year
she hits it nine yeah she's there yeah
totally okay our fifth and final story
kate beckinsale says she's feeling a lot
better after hospitalization i saw this
cate beck and sales on the mend on
monday the actress gave fans an update
on her health sharing a selfie on
instagram which shows the star lying
down with an iv in her arm and a
hospital bracelet on her wrist she said
feeling a lot better thank you so much
for your kind messages and love the
update comes after tmz reported over the
weekend that beckinsale who was it has
been in las vegas filming her new movie
prisoner's daughter was taken to the
hospital for a back issue
a rep for beckinsale did not immediately
respond to people's requests for comment
yeah i heard she like threw her back out
and honestly like relatable yeah i'm
surprised like more people aren't
throwing their backs out yeah like
aren't canceling on me or like even
canceling maybe kylie threw her back out
like that's why she can't go it's a very
plausible thing where like no one can
really know if you're faking it but like
you are completely like debilitated by
it i think even if kylie threw her back
out she would go because it just like
unless she's wearing like a major
headpiece that would like her back
couldn't sustain she could take the
headpiece off right but i think yeah
tell everyone you know kylie threw her
back out that's yeah i'm not going to no
and also like if you're really not
looking forward to something and you
want to cancel like saying you threw
your back out is the best because you
don't have to show any visible signs
like you don't have to have a cough or
like a sweaty nose
but like people who know what it's like
like they won't question if they're like
oh my god can i get you anything it's
actually an amazing excuse yeah but it
must be really bad if she had to go to
the hospital and she's like on yeah
yeah all this what can a hospital even
do for your back nothing right i don't
know
i don't know unless you have like a
herniated disc i don't know a lot about
backs i do i'm sure that you do i really
don't honestly i think in like one of my
yom kippur resolutions like i want to
see a chiropractor like start taking
care of my back i actually people tell
me to go all the time because of my
migraines like to do like physical
therapy and stuff like that it's just
like i'm busy but no i know and like
heart disease part of me like really
feels like
chiropracticity
is like a scam except then i saw real
housewives of salt lake city last night
and do you know that you have like 12
ribs and four in the upper and he's
going to push them back into place
jenny's husband yeah yeah so um well
that's a great transition into our tv
recap which we'll be covering real
housewives of potomac and real
housewives of salt lake city so i think
let's just get patrick out of the way i
agree i'm all we haven't already kept it
in a few weeks i'm all caught up me too
and it's honestly just like fine now
like
everyone like giselle and karen like
were able to like have whatever sort of
piece and that's on because of karen and
i think when karen apologized on carrick
when no one there was like a stalemate
no one's gonna apologize and of course
gisele can't even consider being like
the bigger person because she does not
know what that means
and when karen apologized and it's still
giselle still wouldn't even accept it
because she's like look me in the eye
and so you think karen that was so
[ __ ] rude because she doesn't want to
accept it and so you think that karen is
gonna be like i'm not saying it again
like i [ __ ] said it but karen grown
woman that she is looks her in the eye
heartfelt apology and it's just like you
would have thought before that the
person who apologized first would be the
weak one but it was actually a sign of
strength no she's literally the most
[ __ ] mature [ __ ] i know
and this episode was really bothering me
because like
like this
first it was candace who called ashley a
wide ass like literally what she gave
birth three weeks ago she's first bodied
wide about it she looked literally
better than me like she looks amazing
like she got out of the hospital three
weeks ago
candace is so [ __ ] nasty like that's
such an evil thing to say and then like
giselle called karen like a fat vagina
or whatever like
what
why is nobody calling people like that
so [ __ ] up i don't know and then
candace also was like i'm not saying
you're why i'm not talking about your
body i'm talking about your big face and
your big forehead
oh yeah she went after her too like
right it's so evil like and i feel like
that happens a lot in this group where
maybe it's just like how they talk to
one another where like they say evil
things about each other's appearances
and then they never that's like one of
the things they apologize for that's
just like them like being shady and it's
like i would cry like i literally if i
was actually i would hysterically cry i
can't it was bothering me so much like
no one was even calling it looks like
candace gets hers in next weekend music
video and i hate to be like next week it
looks so good but it does look like
literally
like it's going to be cringe-tastic her
singing career is so fake and like all
she does is like spend her days trying
to like
figure out ways to make it look real to
us she's literally like she's what she's
doing with her
music video class let me show you i know
she's learning tic tocs in her bedroom
oh no i said like her music career is
honestly that of
melania judice i thought that's what
we're gonna do i think melania's a star
a bigger star lonnie's song is so good i
can't wait to grow up no like it just
looks like it all comes crashing down
next week and it's gonna be hilarious to
watch and honestly like i love candace's
mom like she just really [ __ ] lays it
on candace and nobody does like yeah
yeah no but you know what it's so weird
about candace cause like she's bothering
me less and less me too because she's so
team wendy and so am i yeah and like she
is
right on the money 50 of the time she's
not like
she's right with
the wendy stuff but mostly because but
she's wrong on the ashley stuff yeah no
she's wrong about like
everything else yeah but when she's
right like it's it's just it's nice
because we need everyone on our side we
do
but um
honestly like robin talking to her life
coach like i actually would rather gouge
my own
i watch but i fast forward no i know
like robin just hasn't really evolved in
her life or in her
storyline storyline at all like she's
still talking about and it's terrible
like that their friend stole money from
them like it's crazy and it's terrible
but she's still like healing from that
and i'm as a person i'm obviously
understanding of someone taking their
time to heal through their trauma but as
a watcher of television i'm like we've
been talking about this [ __ ] since
season one like get a new line like yeah
it's so boring
yeah i didn't know that that's what her
she said that like that's why she like
has a really hard time trusting people
and like her friendships and even with
juan like they're like just in this like
stagnant place because neither one of
them have like really truly healed from
being so betrayed by a friend
um which makes total sense like human to
human but like i'm watching a television
show like
shut the [ __ ] up like talk about
something else it's so boring
sorry it is yeah and like this life
coach is just like
cool like
life coaches are just you know
in my i think life coaches are vague
like i just feel like if there wasn't
reality tv like life coaches would be
out of a job no and also like why didn't
you just become a therapist like you're
like a life coach is just a therapist
with no ambition
wow that's so mean if you're a life
coach i'm really sorry but like that was
funny yeah i mean maybe you need to see
a life coach based on what you were
saying at the top of the episode
oh my gosh
totally
or a therapist no i don't think therapy
is what you were like what for what you
were saying like no not therapy
no you're but like you want direction no
by the way you're totally right but like
i don't know i could really dig myself
in a hole here i think i'm just gonna
stop talking to you okay cool let's move
on um so i feel like nothing else really
happened in potomac totally no it
and nothing else really happened i just
really like me i just want to say um
i watch watch what happens live last
night because i i don't know like i
forgot to
turn the tv off i forgot to turn the tv
off it was mia and heather heather and
andy was like
so like foreclamped that karen filmed
her surry county thing in
potomac and by the way karen put on her
instagram and she tweeted like they
filmed the the landscape shots in surry
county but the part where just karen was
on camera talking about it was in
potomac they really tried to make an ass
out of karen and it wasn't a big deal i
really tried to make an ass out of her i
assume that's what they were going to do
me too and then we're going to pretend
that this man
was more outraged on watch what happens
live last night that karen filmed the
video for surry county in potomac then
he's been about erica jane and tom jardy
then he's been about shaw then he's been
about any other like atrocity committed
by someone this was the worst thing a
housewife has done no literally could
not get over it no and i just knew like
gisele was like living for this editing
and what like it wasn't a big deal at
all they never pretended that potomac
was surry county
karen clarified on her instagram like
all the landscape shots the shots of the
cornfields that was
surry county yeah
but karen sitting in her gazebo was
obviously in her hometown of potomac
they never pretended like it wasn't
that's like fine by me no it was so like
fraudulent like the way they framed poor
karen hugo they framed her i'm really
sick of it like honestly
nobody [ __ ] respects karen hugo none
of the women not production not andy and
it's disgusting no i'm really just going
to need an andy to bring that energy to
the gen shaw files yeah no andy's like
really disappointing me it's crazy hot i
literally went from like andy cohen was
my he i mean i still really like love
and respect him but he was like
literally my hero like there was no one
in the world i would have rather gone to
dinner with and i just feel like in the
last year like he's just let me down so
much it all started with monique and
then like the walk trappings live from
homes like him being so disinterested
and of course like we all were going
through it so like i'm sympathetic but
like i just feel like he hasn't had any
joint v for his life or like his
business sorry his job being the host of
watch rapping's live i feel like he has
not had an issue out of eve in the last
like two three years and it's just been
like downhill and it's sad because like
i feel like what we all connected with
andy over was like his obsession with
like pop culture being obsessed and like
i don't know i just feel like
he doesn't care anymore so like i don't
either yeah i agree with that let's talk
about uh salt lake city okay yes the
premier of salt lake city was last night
and our recap is brought to you by you
guessed it bowlin branch they know high
quality sleep doesn't stop at your
mattress and their ultra soft organic
sheets are transparently sourced and
produced in safe fair conditions you'll
feel a difference and know you're making
one okay i have all of the bowling brand
sheets and honestly
before they sponsored it the show i
bought them off of a rach parcell
sponsored post which i'm really proud of
that decision because if it's good
enough for rach parcell it's good enough
for all of us and by the way when it
comes to sheets i really really care
about like the cooling technology
because i'm a sweaty sleeper even though
i sleep in an ice box once i get into a
deep circadian rhythm
it's over like i'm getting neck sweat
boob sweat and
the signature hem sheets are the their
beloved bestsellers for a good reason
they get softer with every wash they're
buttery soft lightweight and 100 organic
sateen weave that's perfect for all
seasons they come in a variety of colors
and sizes from twin to california king
they're made to a higher standard with
toxin-free processes and fair trade
certifications to ensure that workers
are being paid livable wages um so if
you're looking to spruce up your home
like start with your bed it's the best
place ever and you should be spending as
much time as possible there to
experience the best sheets you've ever
felt choose bowling branch you can try
them worry free for 30 nights with free
shipping and returns and our listeners
can get an exclusive 15 off your your
first set of sheets with the promo code
toast at bowlingbranch.com
that's b o l l bowl and branch
dot com promo code toast honestly they
never get promo code so like you should
really use this one you know who loves
bowling branch
brew and dew bruins no dude's obsessed
he couldn't even get out of bed this
morning that's why he's not here that's
why he's not here um okay
real housewives of salt lake city
there's obviously like so much going on
there's like two things obviously the
gen chav at all which hasn't even
happened yet but heather was on watch
robin's live last night talking about it
and like really getting under my skin
there's such a weird thing happening
because it seems like since the reunion
like lisa barlow has made the decision
to like be obsessed with jensha and it's
so weird because they never even were
friends and now like lisa's
really like jeopardize jeopardizing her
friendship with meredith in order to be
friends with jen like it's the weirdest
thing ever and heather literally [ __ ]
hates jen with the intensity of ten
thousand sons and will use any excuse to
talk about her and i'm loving it then we
find out this thing about jen where jen
literally defrauded hundreds of people
out of their retirement that jen is
basically like allegedly an evil well
she's been charged with it
yeah i mean there's no way to know if
it's like true until the child but it's
true they don't just go around charging
people for things like that right but
you still have to stay allegedly
so once we find out this piece of
information heather who hates jen
automatically feels his obligation to be
her friend she was on watch robin's live
last night saying that you know jen is
in a position where she needs a friend
right now and heather is going to be
that for her and how basically like this
whole time she knew that jen's business
was quote unsavory but she didn't think
it was illegal um
like an mlm which is just like so weird
heather literally i don't know if she
was drunk but she was like is this live
you saw you watched i did i missed that
no sh like andy asks like how you can
still be friends with her especially
when you're not even friends with her in
the show but now that we know all these
terrible things about her you're even
closer with her
and she was like is this live
and they were like yes watch happens
live and she basically was like i mean
i've known for years that jen's business
was quote unsavory i didn't think it was
illegal um
and now she's just in a position where
she needs a friend and like i'm gonna be
that friend for her it's so weird
and then when all this stuff comes out
it seems like lisa barlow drops gen shot
in an instant so like everything is
backwards everything is backwards and i
just want to say like
lisa barlow i i don't like where that
she's not being like everything that
meredith needs at all times because
meredith deserves everything no and that
conversation on the couch was so
it was gaslighting i'm sorry to pretend
like what lisa's going through with
heather is even remotely close i didn't
know half that social media stuff i
think that's gaslighting i think that's
just wrong i think it's gaslighting like
belittling meredith's feelings to like
the moronic fight between whitney
heather bad weather oh my god stop okay
so
but i was just gonna say like lisa
barlow is coming back for me like she
and i just feel like throughout this
season like i'm just going to be liking
her more and more i think so too and i
feel like
season one we just didn't understand her
personality i don't think i still do
but
i think we're like getting a sense of it
where it's like
i don't know i just could see myself
liking her
not currently because i think like she's
being such a bad friend to meredith
first of all i had no idea all of the
social media stuff like about brooks and
by the way i don't even like brooks but
like you do not go after someone's kid
you do not
like a post where someone calls
i think the t word is a slur for gay
people yeah so like you that's so [ __ ]
up first of all like i don't know how
married like
it's crossed a line to the point of like
not like we all need to get together and
talk about it it's like how does why
would meredith ever be taught be friends
with this woman ever again no and lisa
doesn't understand that she's trying to
like encourage some sort of reunion
which is like
that's not how it goes once you come for
someone's kid like you can never be
friends with that person ever again ever
and like i can't even stress enough how
much like i'm not even like a fan of
brooks but like literally of course
meredith should never speak to jen again
and yes it's a direct betrayal i thought
it was crazy that like literally lisa's
in meredith's house with meredith's kids
sitting on the couch defending a woman
who called
her son a slur like it's so backwards
like you're in her home right now no and
who continues to like all of these mean
things about brooks it's like meredith's
your friend like what are you doing
liking this stuff
and meredith is your real friend of 10
years before the show i don't think that
lisa and jen really knew each other
before the show right it's just it's so
bizarre to me but hopefully it
it starts to clear itself up eventually
and i think i saw in a preview for
something like somebody asks lisa if
she's in business with jen i know i
thought that was really interesting and
that would explain why she's kind of
blindly defending jen but that would
also explain why she turned
jen's in legal trouble goodbye right
because like she ran with lisa's money
or something
yeah or like she doesn't want to be near
the smell of any of this yeah and i'm
having a really hard time because
heather is my girl like that scene where
they were all ordering food like i was
hysterically laughing she's like these
skinny [ __ ] but
then on watch rapunzel's live i'm like i
don't recognize this person like and i'm
afraid i may have like started to stand
prematurely a premature stan a premature
stanhood but you know who i didn't
prematurely stand meredith marks agreed
all i'll say about heather is let it
play out
i mean i don't see myself you know going
to team jen but just let it play out you
don't have to make any decisions right
now maybe you'll understand maybe she's
been through something similar or
something like and maybe you'll
understand why she's doing what she's
doing
yeah maybe just let it play out um
there were so many funny moments wait
but there was also two major things that
happened first of all meredith got a new
house and it's absolutely gorgeous yes
gorgeous but i feel like she said we
finally got a home that was more
reflective of our style because her old
house was like literally from the 60s
yeah it's shade but
i remember when contracts were going out
last season and everybody was like
talking about who's coming back like
meredith had to get a house yeah because
she i guess she didn't have one in utah
so it's obviously like a rental yeah
whatever whatever
scene and honestly like just
looks good cook there the meredith mark
like stand inside me like i just there
was just something not right about that
house from last season like this house
is right i know but like where do they
actually live not that i think that
they're like
hiding anything but where do they live i
don't know like it's a good question
they had said that like she had got a
home for three like a six month rental
first production but like jen is in a
rental and she's hiding something yeah
jenna but see you know the thing is
that's what i was thinking last night
like when we were recapping last season
like everyone was just saying like we
don't really understand like the gen
shaw money of it all and it's just so
crazy how like right we were like all of
our instincts were like a hundred
percent oh but we like never understand
the money you know we like are so
concerned about the money with the beer
men's but they're not coming to jail
like but the [ __ ] or to read but see
like okay with the biermanns like i'm so
confused because they spend so much but
they also have like a million businesses
like yeah you know the cosmetics the
skin care they're in walmart like this
show the show they actually work you
know for jen it was like she is
up into the reunion like i thought she
didn't have a job she was a party
planner right and then her husband like
was a part-time football coach assistant
he's very full-time assistant football
coach for college where like the going
salary is like 500 grand a year which is
obviously a very nice salary but not for
the life that they were pretending to
live so i just want to say like we were
all right and that made me feel good
that's what i was thinking when i watch
her new home is beautiful though right
but then like people also have questions
about like mary and her money and no but
mary is explaining how like she they
literally own like tons of fast food
restaurants they have like tons of real
estate i mean it's confusing because all
of her homes are like weird and run down
but she explained how she made her money
yeah but then also jen did at the
reunion what did she say her company did
like retargeting like facebook ads and
[ __ ]
remember they asked yes yes she had an
answer a good one yeah it was like some
sort of marketing it was something she
rehearsed it was some sort of
multi-level marketing literally okay and
then what was the second big thing that
happened for you
that you said two big things meredith
moved i did say that
but you're really following up well
because i just want to get to the part
that made me laugh heather i mean i'm
married whitney oh oh yeah yeah i what
made me laugh was whitney dropping the
cake like that was actually so that
party looked like so fun and real her
life is just like
so cute cute and it just seems she seems
really happy yeah it is weird that like
she has a 29 year old stepson and she's
34. no it's sure it's unconventional but
they're they seem so [ __ ] happy like
they're constantly like in bathing suits
in their hot tub just like drinking and
having a good time no totally and like
they have this foam machine just like
chilling in the garage like it's so
weird and also like all the kids like
are come over and they love her and it's
so cute has she spoken about those kids
mom i'm curious like what if they get
along like oh i don't know because also
like their their marriage justin and
whitney has is so it's like tomorrow but
also now we know why wild rose is in her
yes because she's like throwing that
birthday party yeah no because it's the
name of her brand
oh not birthday party yeah did she not
say she was also gonna have a birthday
party and that was a theme oh i don't
know about that but she said like she
has a beauty brand and it's gonna be
called wild rose i mean like so now like
it's some low level like season one
housewife like starting a beauty break
she's on season two so leave her that's
fine
it was an existing beauty brand so she
has to pass and i was very happy for her
like okay what made me laugh the hardest
is when mary was doing her podcast
and one of the guys on the podcast with
her like mary said like lead us in
prayer and he starts like doing his
prayer and he's like picking up energy
and ruach and and he's getting spirit is
with him he's getting really into it and
mary's like stop not like that and i
just feel like if someone cut you off in
the middle of a passionate prayer
i can't think of anything more
embarrassing no totally and especially
like when that person is cutting you off
like is your spiritual leader like when
they're like you're doing it wrong and
you're being extra like you suck and
you're ugly like you're right like
calling someone's prayer style
essentially extra like is just
so hurtful no also like when we saw
mary's church it looks like they
encouraged the extraness like everyone's
like dancing like right and he was just
like getting into it like leave him
alone i literally wanted to cry for him
can i tell you like i didn't even remark
at the moment i i honestly can't even
remember what you're talking about um
but you called me you're like did you
see and you're like in stitches i'm like
i was so unphased i'm like i don't even
i must have been on my phone i'm like i
don't even know what you're talking
about you need to go back and watch now
i can't think of anything that would cut
me down more no totally especially if
you're like a deeply spiritual person
right and honestly mary is just his i
i'm a big mary fan yeah i am i like her
even on her podcast when she's like
just you know usually i don't like
gizelle and robin i did not care to hear
about their podcast you just get to see
a different side of mary and like she's
clearly very spiritual and it's
interesting and then also when she was
at lunch with the girls in the igloo
like she's also like a cool friend i
know i feel like nobody ever includes
her it's like seeing her at the at lunch
with the girls it was like seeing like a
dog walk on a time like it was so
bizarre like it's like seeing my teacher
out of school so appropriate and even
meredith with her she was really funny
like like and then we have a spiritual
leader here to get you through your
grief meredith like you know talk to you
with friends you can do both totally i
thought i by the way it just didn't feel
weird seeing her there like yeah like
what are you doing out of the church
like
almost like she's a vampire and like if
she sees direct sunlight like it was
just very bizarre no it was very bizarre
but i i really i'm glad i like mary too
i think she's like well intended you
know pending the fact that she's not
like a cult leader right well we'll see
about all that and also i just have to
say meredith marx's first interview look
is so the pink the pink
gorgeous and like she's sitting there
crying about her dad and it's so sad but
i can't help but like think like you are
literally gorgeous like she looked
amazing i and her kids are gorgeous yes
her daughter's by the way we need more
daughter because it's a lot of brooks
right and she showed up with the prayer
and so she has bonus points and she's
got the ruach in her and i just loved
and like her glam like kid and i was
thinking about like kids these days how
like every they all know how to do
perfect makeup i wonder if she got her
makeup done because like she knew she's
gonna be it didn't look like maybe she
got like meredith's makeup artists like
did a touch up maybe or like meredith
like three but it looked perfect yeah no
i just love this new house for my earth
i don't even want to think about the
fact that it might be fake and brooks
did a really good job with the challah
and you know what i'm i'm turning fresh
i agree i'm turning over a new leaf with
brooks because
i think he got up to a rocky start with
most of the viewers last season but now
like seeing other people being mean to
him i'm like no that's not that's not
what we're doing nobody comes for brook
brooks except us
so i
i'm leaving everything from last season
mostly because i forget why i didn't
like it by the way literally me too i
thought the same thing i'm like i'm
starting fresh with brooks like and i'm
and i'm fully defending him against jen
shaw like a grown woman coming after him
and like honestly i thought meredith's
answer for like his sexuality which i
think a lot of people have just been
like wondering about i think she had the
most perfect answer like he's figuring
it out leave him alone he's a child and
you know what 100 agreed and so i'm
ready for you know for brooks and i to
have a new relationship for season two
but i do feel like he was very burned by
the reaction from season one and i don't
think we'll be seeing him a lot he
didn't say a word last night he thought
the same thing but brooks you killed it
with the challah um no even beautiful he
was wearing her track suit i was like
that's cute i thought it was sweet
whitney was wearing the tracksuit too
like i thought it was nice yeah i
thought it was nice it's just crazy how
time heals everything no it does because
like last season i was like i'm gonna
stop watching the show because of this
like when andy wore tracksuit i was like
so extra but now i'm just like brooks
you do your thing yeah don't let the
haters like us still let the haters get
you down and we are we were the haters
no but i'm i'm 100 with you like fresh
start fresh start so it was a really
good season premiere um and it was an
hour and a half it was hour 15 i was
like so confused because i looked over
it's 100 i'm like why am i still
watching this um i didn't mind at all
because the conversation was really
heating up between lisa and meredith um
i just feel like i'm at such a good
place now with the real houses of salt
lake city like i can tell lisa and
meredith apart now and i'm just so
excited to be here like really and truly
and i really like the new housewife so
far oh yeah um but you know what i'm
realizing crazy story i know and i'm so
excited to like learn more about her and
just get to know her but what i'm
realizing i feel like with so many of
the new housewives that we've seen it's
like they come out like really strong in
the first episode or two i'm like yes
perfect casting then we never [ __ ]
hear from them again like mia
yeah crystal
yeah
that's a good call yeah i think it'll be
easier for on salt lake city for jenny
because it's a new franchise but yeah
that's just like a thought that i had no
i like me that's so strong and now she's
just like a wall flower and like kind of
wishy-washy no she's like a people
pleaser so like she doesn't she's kind
of spineless like she takes everyone's
side i yes but then i'm watching what
happens inside last night like she was
full of spine what did she say like she
was um
like first of all she loves karen like
and sometimes it's like unclear on the
show yeah because she's also like you
have a she's a heart gizelle right but
then like someone asked her a shady
[ __ ] question
and like one of the audience members and
she just like shut that [ __ ] down real
quick with a smile so i was like okay
you go girl okay yeah you know but she
has become like somewhat irrelevant yeah
that's just what i was saying yeah so
hopefully that's not the story for jenny
but i would actually love to hear more
about her fleeing vietnam vietnam right
like this is a situation where like
please more home and personal scenes no
it was crazy
and her kids were so cute and just like
beijing and her yeah so funny
relationship with her husband seems
great and i just and i like that she has
a 10-year friendship with lisa like
right and like i just love when someone
comes in with like a good amount of
money and it
makes sense like her husband's a doctor
like it makes sense why she has money
and i don't have any questions and a
personality yeah she was super funny and
a story yeah so i think it was a great
casting and this is just like literally
my favorite show yeah no i wasn't i
thought
i was being like you know kind of a
naysayer about it i was like like
something else but i'm so glad to have
them back and now like i just need
winter to be here oh my gosh we have to
go to utah like
no by the way the fact that like heather
like just showed up and showed up at
meredith's house i was like why isn't
that our life no literally it's like how
the way like we would go get like a
pretzel they just like go ski down a
mountain literally must be so fun
so fun did she like ski over to meredith
literally meredith might live on the
mountain like
yeah and then do you think meredith pays
for the whole rental or a production
helps her if like i don't want to live
in a world where she doesn't pay for the
whole production but like rental she
shouldn't really have to like they
wanted i'm sorry this is a show about
people's lives and like you all need a
house
fine
fine brew will accept it i'm just like
what is
what's her husband's name seth doing
over there in ohio like make meredith
some money so she can buy her own house
yeah well pressure's on
i think they have their own house but
not in maybe they don't want to live in
salt lake city
you know maybe
do you think that meredith was the one
who i think meredith okay this is what
i'm thinking i think meredith lives in
park city and she's got a lot of film in
park city and that's where her store is
yeah so i think she has to get a rental
when she wants to be in salt lake
maybe
even though they're not that far from
each other it's like 40 minutes do you
think that meredith was the one who
tipped the feds off that she would be at
beauty lab no me neither i think that
there's a million [ __ ] people who
work on the show there's a million
people who work for jen i think the feds
probably got to one of her like
low-level shaw squad assistants and was
like well you know what's your schedule
you've been involved in a crime if you
want to get off uh where can we find
miss shaw yeah and no this insinuation
that it was meredith like that's no and
it seems like it becomes like a huge
focal point which is so annoying
accusing the manzos like yeah right but
the thing is it's like it becomes a
focal point which is so annoying because
then we're not talking about what jen
actually did we're it's because i didn't
see one conversation of people asking
jen like how do you feel about the fact
that you stole from old and vulnerable
vulnerable people they're all obsessed
with like well how did they know she was
at beauty lab who cares yeah they were
gonna find her she wasn't on the run
probably on that day there were 100
people who knew that jen would be like
production like there's a million people
why would it be meredith except meredith
did say something like really ominous at
lunch like about how jen's going through
she's going to need friends how she's
going through her hard time or something
oh i miss that she did it was weird but
then also jen said something ominous i'm
gonna say i've never been to prison
right
yeah that was homeless [ __ ]
yeah
um so yeah it was a lot of television to
watch last night but i really enjoyed it
yeah it was pretty good and tonight is
bachelor in paradise which we don't
watch but margaret will know but i've
been hearing like good things so i'm
glad that you guys are enjoying it and
unfortunately tuesday is tomorrow night
is the real housewives of new york
reunion like they took a break or
whatever but it's here i think have you
seen a preview no but it has to be right
i don't know i haven't seen a commercial
not even last night when i was yeah
that's true
do you watch commercials right yeah all
of them so no there's no way oh my god
you're right
are they just not gonna air the reunion
i don't know they'll wait longer they
did film something like that two weeks
so then why what didn't salt lake city
premiere on tuesday
yeah having back to back was annoying
yeah i'm sure they'll move it something
into tuesday but sunday night is like
where the good shows go like if you get
a sunday night slot on broadway that
means you have good ratings i guess but
for me for me as a viewer
i don't think it works yeah i don't love
it like sunday
like because that's because we view it
as
work yeah and then it's like we're doing
work on the weekends even though it's
not like that but um work
yeah so oh i'll just share the other
stuff that i watched this weekend which
was i finished my book the social graces
okay about mrs astor and alva vanderbilt
and it definitely got me like curious
about you know gilded age new york
and i saw in the bibliography that the
author said she got a lot of like her
content from like this rick burns
documentary about new york and i'd heard
of it before so it's on amazon it's an
eight part docu series each episode is
like an hour and a half and it's the
history of new york from like the dutch
in 1624
till i think till now right now i'm in
like
1880
so but it's really like some of it is
like definitely drags a little bit but
there's so many interesting factoids
it's like crazy like the street names
and like why certain areas are called
what they're called and like just the
the city planning the grid central park
so much interest the erie canal like and
it's crazy because i've learned so much
of this and i actually took a class in
college like the history of new york so
i've
i've watched this movie and still so
much of it is new to me because like
until you care about something it's just
not gonna resonate you know that's the
thing like kids really shouldn't go to
school like so young cause like they
don't give a [ __ ] you know
no if you want them to remember
something like go when they're 30. no
it's so true like i obviously know that
of the erie canal but i had no idea of
like the districts
the significance the strategic because
you learned it when you didn't care
because i learned it when i didn't care
and that's also like remember how i said
i took a class like history of russia
and then i was reading a book about you
know the romanovs only to find out that
the whole family was murdered the whole
royal family i'm like this is news to me
but i know that i've heard it before why
because you didn't care because i didn't
care enough normalize like starting
middle school at the age of 30. yeah so
any and also and also
it's giving me this star q series is
giving me
an a renewed appreciation for new york
just like the spirit of things and like
why new york is the way that it is and
like what we all
sacrifice living here but like why we do
that you know so i just feel like i've
been
i've been hard on my city in recent
years
and it's good to
remember the good times you know and
and just
see what makes us us here as new yorkers
totally so it's good if anybody is
looking for a little history um it's
rick burns is new york on amazon you
have to buy the whole thing so i'm going
episode by episode but i'm sure
eventually i'll just you know
buy the rest for 3.99 yeah like finish
the package yeah totally and brew's been
enjoying it because there's horses and
stuff and there's there's also dogs and
so and he likes learning about
[ __ ] you scared the [ __ ] out of me bruno
oh my god
he likes learning about his city oh my
god he gave me a fright jesse oh he
didn't get me afraid i saw it i saw it
all going down i didn't see any of it um
okay well that sounds nice i didn't
really watch any tv this weekend look at
you hey look at me i'm like just so in
the moment you know that's you
so
that's me and that's our show that is
our show you guys thank you guys so much
for listening to the morning toast the
millennial morning show where we deliver
the past five stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcasts can be found so it's spotify
itunes stitcher public radio i heard we
do catch box all the places this way we
listen to a podcast my next morning tell
us leave a five star review about a
beautiful
and smart we are hope you guys have an
amazing [ __ ] day and if you're still
here congratulations you've made it to
the society season two to prove your
loyalty to the morning toast drop a
comment on our most recent instagram and
make it the emoji of
like the crab
crap i don't know if there's a crab one
lobster you have a visitor lobster
lobster because bruno house gout have a
great day everyone we'll see you
tomorrow bye
you